people need to understand that all of
North America is indigenous land it is
native land people tend to forget that
there was a vibrant native culture
living in all parts of North America and
food is really the piece that's going to
help us move forward into a brighter
future my name is Sean Sherman and I am
a shot I own the company of the sous
chef so this was going to be two pieces
per plate for these our mission is
revitalizing Native American foods and
riah denta fiying North American cuisine
we've tried really hard to maintain
authenticity by removing all of the
colonial ingredient like dairy wheat
flour processed sugar beef pork chicken
and we're just using a lot of wild game
a lot of the native agricultural
heirloom varieties a lot of the wild
foods around us and really making those
plates that tastes like a region
most of these ingredients are very
familiar to people but the usage of a
lot of the wild plant really talked
about a place in a community we
prioritize purchasing from the
indigenous vendors first because we
really want to open up a lot of
opportunity for indigenous people
growing out firearms or collecting
things from the wild or raising animal
so for the big dinner we're actually
cooking this bison down with a bunch of
fresh cedar and some bergamot we will
purchase from anybody raising these
indigenous pieces because it is such an
important part of the landscape in the
history you know you want it as we
travel around the country we like to
make dinners and foods that really
represent those areas what's great about
being able to do these dinners
especially in non-indigenous communities
is just to bring awareness this kind of
food that we're eating today like you're
going to feel really good when you leave
here you're not going to feel heavy and
weighted down you're going to feel
energized and just happy because you're
knowing where the food is coming from
we feel like anybody across North
America will benefit from the
understanding of the indigenous food
systems around you and it's all going to
help us move forward
you
[Music]